-♪ We're cool bartenders ♪
♪ Soul patches and suspenders ♪
♪ And when it comes
to being hip ♪
♪ We are repeat offenders ♪
♪ Candied lemon, twist of lime ♪
♪ Peppercorns,
a sprig of thyme ♪
♪ Lavender, Curacao ♪
♪ You'll drink it up
and be like, "Wow" ♪
-♪ Take some bourbon,
take some mint ♪
♪ Simple syrup, add it in ♪
♪ Pour it in a julep cup ♪
♪ That'll cost you 50 bucks ♪
-♪ We're cool bartenders ♪
♪ Soul patches and suspenders ♪
♪ Ernest Hemingway quotes ♪
♪ In the bios of our Tinders ♪
-♪ If you want it on the rocks ♪
♪ We've got you covered, dude ♪
♪ Our ice comes
only in two sizes ♪
♪ Crushed or giant cube ♪
-♪ We forgot to mention ♪
♪ You can't get our attention ♪
♪ We don't hear you over there ♪
♪ We're listening to Bon Iver ♪
♪ Olives and raw sugar cane ♪
♪ We imported both from Spain ♪
♪ Pomegranate, cardamom ♪
♪ We imported both from Guam ♪
-♪ Charcoal, beet juice,
pine nuts, cocoa ♪
-♪ Ginger, chartreuse,
figs, Four Loko ♪
-♪ Amaretto, coriander,
celery, and honeydew ♪
-♪ No matter what you
order, you can bet that
we are judging you ♪
-♪ Armagnac, tequila, rum,
you won't be leaving soberly ♪
-♪ Take a sip of mine
and tell me how it
tastes like potpourri ♪
-♪ The only beer we have
is IPA ♪
-♪ Pale ale ♪
-♪ The only beer we have
is IPA ♪
-♪ This one's pumpkin! ♪
-♪ No pilsners, no stouts ♪
♪ That's not what we're about ♪
-♪ Tastes bad ♪
-♪ No lagers, no porters,
we control... ♪
-♪ You want an old-fashioned? ♪
-♪ We'll make it new ♪
-♪ Want a margarita? ♪
-♪ We'll make it blue ♪
-♪ Dry martini ♪
-♪ We'll make it wet ♪
-♪ Just one drink ♪
-♪ You'll be in debt ♪
-♪ We're cool bartenders ♪
♪ Soul patches and suspenders ♪
♪ It's closing time
for this song ♪
♪ And this line is our ender ♪